[Music]
hello welcome to every damn day we're
all weird costumes and these costumes
have something in common and what that
is these are all Bruce Willis characters
from his various movies and the reason
we're doing this is in honor of the
Roast of Bruce Willis on Comedy Central
on July 29th earlier this week we asked
you to tell us which characters to dress
up as and these were the answers
everybody introduce yourselves Chris
let's start with you shout out I of them
dressed as John McLean from diehard
glass this was the top vote of
suggestion on our YouTube community pool
looking good and which particular John
McLean our good choice I thought you
were Martin Lawrence from Bad Boys and
this was the top voted suggestion from
youtuber Clayton King and it's
particularly right after the ball gag
incident and I noticed that you weren't
able to go through hair and makeup this
morning so you had to just come as you
were when you left Jordan what are you
wearing hi I'm RJ the raccoon from over
the head shout out to it's hard to be
just a little hard to hear you
yeah maybe shadow to goodfeathers
outdoors I think that's a plan
Goodfellas very funny thing about these
outfits is that Ryan and I already had
them from having sex with each other
yeah it's more of a lifestyle than and I
know before you write it in the comments
I know not all furries are into it for
the sex but a lot of you are
what do you got going on around oh I am
the Easter Bunny from Bruce Willis's
famed performance in the movie north why
am I the Easter Bunny because my brother
wrote on the YouTube community section
that Ryan should be Bruce Willis
character from North mostly because I'm
his older brother and I feel like the
world needs to see him in a bunny
costume
I've got enough upvotes for that to
happen and so here we are
Thank You Ryan's brother and thank you
to everyone else who commented including
Andres vergin in the YouTube section he
told us that one of us should be the
roughneck astronaut from Armageddon aka
Harry a Stamper the best deep-sea oil
drilled man in the entire world and
that's who I am
guys let's get into the discussion I
want to start off what is your favorite
Bruce Willis movie what's the best one
and are any of you by coincidence in a
character from your favorite just so
happens that your boy here this is my
favorite movie
die hard with a vengeance is great I
mean I wanted to come and say I'm Jack
but there was like nine you gotta be
Bruce Willis I'm like I'm cool dad I
wish he had the sandwich board I mean
look I wanted to say it was bored I want
to go white face neatly
they said no one both so I'm here who
knew racial slurs weren't popular on
YouTube I mean why not even use the
racial slur or use the white face either
way I'm gonna get the same comments I
think that you asked if you can do white
face probably like a dozen you didn't
bring it up just once
including right before we started you
just made sure I think the way to do
this is you go back in my day we were
white
I mean diehards a great choice anyone
else favorite movie diehards great Sixth
Sense is great don't sleep on that one
what else has he been in that I really
might be my favorite I think I'm a tie
between fifth element and looper looper
your favorite actually went as Joseph
gordon-levitt from looper and every
costume you want to see my Joseph what
do you mean wait like when right now oh
wait so you are not actually the raccoon
you're saying that you are Joe I'm Jung
looper there's a deep like it's like an
inception of impressions of characters
inception also Joseph gordon-levitt I
want to pin it let's all say our
favorite Joseph gordon-levitt movie no I
am joking that's not what we're here to
do is there any chance that North is the
best
Bruce low life North not a chance North
is the worst movie he's been in Wow but
my girlfriend really legitimately likes
it she got so excited when I told her
like she figured out I didn't even tell
her she figured out what I was going to
be and North is critically just totally
trashed on Roger Ebert the late Roger
Ebert said about North and Bruce Willis
performance in it funny funny thinks
north this guy looks familiar about
Bruce Bruce Willis he goes and so he is
all of the manifestations are played by
Bruce Willis who is not funny or helpful
in any of them I hated this movie hated
hated hated hated hated this movie hated
it hated every simpering stupid vacant
audience insulting moment of it hated
the sensibility that thought anyone
would like it hated the implied insult
to the audience by its belief that
anyone would be entertained by it
Wow I liked it so much who who would win
in a fight between all of the Bruce
Willis characters who is his strongest
fighter in all the movies I'm gonna go
with the guy covered in blood between
between us here's do you think butch
would be John McClane
it depends it depends if you put them in
the room butch wins if you put them in a
building John McLean the boxer if you
have a whole building to work with John
McLean all day but if you have a room
that's it
it's all butch I like that his character
uses a build a building as like a
tactical weapon I know who definitely
lose which is Bruce Willis from death
becomes her cue plays like a very like
normal office yeah I carry more
authority dress like a child's astronaut
costume looks like would that I could
thanks for having some fun with us today
please check out the roast of Bruce
Willis on Comedy Central on July 29th
and then in the meantime we've got
another thing we want to show you right
now Bruce Willis he's a movie star a
musician and a father of five but who
really is Bruce Willis I've dug deep
into the Getty image archives to give
you a more accurate picture of who
really is Bruce Willis what is Bruce
Willis a style hard to pin down
sometimes it's Italian gangster on
vacation
sometimes it's Slovak Miley Cyrus
sometimes it's a guy auditioning for
Alvin and the Chipmunks I mean come on
what does Bruce Willis like gossiping
with men who wear pinkie ring hiding
mints in his teeth and getting a massage
from a raccoon while a shittier version
of Bruce Willis watches
what does Bruce Willis hate Puff Daddy
what does Bruce Willis regret that one
time you got confused and thought he was
interviewing a soldier but really it's
just a headless mannequin
we've all been there buddy so who is
Bruce Willis many would say he's a
multi-million dollar movie star but deep
down I say he's just a guy who loves
hats here's a minute
and here's him in a hat and here's him
in a hat and here's everyone else
without a hat Bruce says I want hat
here's him in a hat surprise it's two
heads this guy hates it goodbye
I'm Bruce Willis I love hats hi I'm
Hannah Dickinson and this is cheers to
you I'm taking off my first round of the
weekend bye cheers you to all the people
and stories that encouraged me to drink
Cheers you for a night for bringing over
a billion dollars for those of you who
don't play for a night it's a video game
where you build forts for those of you
who do play a dollar is something you'll
earn when you finally get a job cheers
to you are Kelly for your song I admit
it's 19 minutes long but just happens to
be the average age of the girls trapped
in his basement
cheers to Ivanka Trump for discontinuing
your fashion line to focus on public
policy I think that's great and at least
you can still express your creativity
through interior design cheers you naked
man at Planet Fitness who claims it's a
judgment-free zone a nice try buddy but
I feel judged by your lack of erection
cheers to you jenna jameson for losing
50 pounds
that weight went down faster than you
did in any of your films and lastly
cheers to you Bruce Willis you're
getting roasted this Sunday July 29 I
personally prefer people talk about
me behind my back
or in the YouTube comments section see
you there bitches Cheers
it's been brought to my attention that
during the discussion I might have had a
bulge issues it to be the tightness of
my costume and I just like to apologize
to all of you if anyone inadvertently
saw saw that I hope everybody watching
goes back and re-watch is it just and
screenshots it's windy backsies no
rewind 'back season I didn't notice do
not skip back I use the little thing to
little foal certainly make it of me do
not use markup no thank me make the
arrow is all coming in like four hand
rolls no means nothing a meme would be
like when you're about to go to HR no
don't want to thank you everyone and
we'll see you on the next episode of
every day I'm day it'll be after the
roast and I think we're gonna talk about
it by 8:00 I mean where that held was
like a condom
[Music]
you